for two years he's had a starring role
at the very center of the me2 movement
now comes the first courtroom test of
whether Harvey Weinstein is in the words
of a prosecutor are rapists not just a
Hollywood Titan the walking frame he'd
used following back surgery was no
longer required but he was physically
supported by his attorney their role is
to destroy the credibility of his
accusers telling the court any
relationship was transactional and
consensual judge James Burke told the
seven men and five women on the jury
that this case was not a referendum on
the me2 movement on sexual harassment or
on women's rights it was about whether a
crime has been committed and whether the
facts of the case have been proven but
the prosecution say that Weinstein
abused his role as a movie producer in
her opening statement the assistant
district attorney in Meghan hast accused
Weinstein of sexually assaulting these
women when they refused to comply with
his desires and his orders and then
using his power and prestige in the
entertainment industry to ensure their
silence the lawyer who represents some
of the women involved was in court
I expect that those witnesses will be
very very brave when they do testify and
when they are subject to what I have no
doubt will be a very vigorous and
perhaps a brutal cross-examination of
each one Weinstein's lawyers tried to
get the case moved from Manhattan
because of what they called the media
circus around the trial adding to that
the oscar-winning actor Cuba Gooding jr.
he was appearing in the same court
building on charges of groping several
women he denies it on just a few hundred
yards away a film crew are shooting a TV
series but nothing fictional will match
the drama being played out in the
Weinstein court case over the coming
weeks if Weinstein is acquitted it'll be
a blow to the dozens of women who have
accused him have been a monster but it
won't end the story he's facing another
a sexual assault trial in Los Angeles in
Woods at Sky News New Yor